hey youtubers is Charlie so everybody
was freaking out when they released this
Gilly preview of her reading about Azure
hi so I'm going to explain why that's so
important what the show has left out
from the book in the prince who was
promised so careful for spoilers for
everything that's happened on the show
so far there's some really big stuff
that's coming up that I talked about at
the end of the video if you new to the
channel there's a new round of the game
of Thrones giveaway happening it's for a
copy of the enhanced editions of the
books all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so we got to talk about this Gilly
page that she's reading
why is she reading about Azure 'hi in
how that's competing with the idea of
the prince who was promised there are
two competing theories but the big
reveal is that they both talked about
the same mythical figure is going to
save them from the coming darkness which
in modern context is the night king in
his army the second long night so what's
happening here is that Gilly is actually
reading a page from the world of Ice and
Fire book in real life but she's not
reading about azor Ahai specifically
she's reading about the long night in
azor Ahai as mentioned during this
passage so I'll read what it says here
so it's kind of hard to make out but
this is what the texts that she's
looking at reads it says it is also
written that there are animals in a shy
of such a darkness and of a hero who
fought against it with a red sword his
deeds are said to have been performed
before the rise of Valyria in the
earliest ages when old geese was first
forming its empire this legend has
spread west from a shy in the followers
of the red God claim that this hero was
named azor Ahai and prophesy his return
in the Jade compendium votar recounts a
curious legend from ET which states that
the Sun hid his face from the earth for
a lifetime a shame that something none
could discover in that that disaster was
averted only by the deeds of a woman
with a monkey's tail so there are a
whole bunch of questions raised by this
passage but you see that Samwell isn't
so much learning about the prince who
was promised or azor Ahai he's trying to
learn about the night king in the White
Walkers which is bringing up old legends
of mythical Savior figures and obviously
they talk about a woman in this
particular legend but this passage that
she's reading is actually
from a much larger text on the long
night it actually reads about some other
legends that other cultures have about
their mythical savior Lomas long Strider
is another author from Westeros who
wrote a book called wonders made by man
where he talks to people descended from
the Rhoyne ur and they talk about this
legend from their homeland where they
had a version of the long night the
river froze over darkness came and it
became a parable for how the people had
to come together as one to unify put
aside their bickering to sing a secret
song that brought the day back so there
are a lot of different people all over
the world that have different ways of
talking about the long night in how it
was solved they had to come together as
one there had to be a mythical figure so
the TV show tends to change a lot of
things from the books and not a lot of
the characters put a lot of faith in the
idea of prophecy Daenerys has visions
Jon Snow is the most practical person
ever so a lot of people that want to
believe that he is the prince was
promised like Melisandre now might tell
him that but really this is all about
Samwell trying to find hard information
that will help them in their immediate
fight but in the background what the
show is doing is just sort of laying
clues for really big reveals in the
funny thing here that I haven't seen
anybody talking about is the idea that
Gilly is reading a page-one it's amazing
that she's reading at all but to that
it's actually written in English like so
that we as viewers could zoom in on the
page and make out the text so when a TV
show does stuff like this there's
usually for two reasons one it's so that
the actor can just read off the page in
a Gilly would be able to convey that
information to Samwell or two so that
they could zoom in even if the page does
not get read and we as the audience
could see what that reads and take clues
from that oh they're talking about azor
Ahai the mythical figure we've been
talking about Jon Snow coming back we've
been talking about Daenerys born again
amid salt and smoke so the thing about
the prince that was promised is that
this theory has been around for a much
longer time through Rhaegar Targaryen
character Daenerys got a version of it
in the books but like Lomas long
Striders book in the passage that Gilly
is reading they're all talking about the
same idea it is that all the characters
haven't realized that yet engineers is
still
trying to interpret her visions and
she's no better than Melisandre added so
when she's in the house of the undying
this is sort of the crash course in the
prophecy of the prince who was promised
that she gets the prophecy that Rhaegar
Targaryen was obsessed with in believed
that his baby Aegon was the culmination
of so I'll read this passage she's
walking through the house of the undying
and then it reads the man had her
brother's hair but he was taller in his
eyes were a dark indigo rather than a
lilac Aegon he said to a woman nursing a
newborn babe in a great wooden bed what
better name for a king
will you make a song for him the woman
asked he has a song the man replied he
is the prince that was promised and his
is the Song of Ice and Fire he looked up
when he said it and his eyes met danny's
and it seemed as if he saw her standing
there beyond the door there must be one
more he said though whether he was
speaking to her or to the woman in the
bed she could not say the dragon has
three heads so there are a couple
different ideas in here there's the idea
of the prince who was promised then
there's the idea of the dragon has three
heads so people talk about those as two
separate things who are the three heads
of the Dragon who is the prince who was
promised so what Rhaegar is doing here
is he's talking about the idea of the
prophecy of azor Ahai beating back the
long night so he's obsessed with the
idea of this coming darkness and that as
part of that there will be a
three-headed dragon to beat it back in
the biggest part of that is his newborn
baby Aegon so you see the way the TV
show changes things and going back a
couple years fans have had a lot of
theories about this vision that she has
because the woman nursing the newborn
baby is not necessarily Elia Martell his
wife up in King's Landing
Daenerys does not notice the area that
the baby has been born it is just a
wooden bed with Rhaegar the woman and
her nursing it in him talking about the
idea of the prince that was promised so
it's very ambiguous and that makes you
think if the TV show is going to connect
this moment with this baby and they will
actually named Jon Snow of the TV show
that Aegon baby from the vision but a
lot of you know about the valonqar
prophecy and how the TV show completely
cut that out the idea that Cersei is
going to be killed by the little brother
there's a couple reasons why the TV show
cuts out big things like this because it
foreshadows really big twist in the
future in one the TV show which has
changed a lot of plot points in the past
could choose to go in a completely
different direction with the characters
did the prophecies talk about into the
other reason to cut that out is because
visually if they were to show that
vision on-screen it would completely
spoil the big reveal that would be
happening
many many seasons later because if you
remember the house of the undying was in
season two so imagine if you saw a
version of this scene here in season two
you'd be like who's that that's not Elia
Martell and this is not King's Landing
this is the Tower of joy oh my god is
that baby Jon Snow
it would have completely spoiled the
reveal from the end of season six so
what it seems like is the books and the
TV show are conspiring to reveal Jon
Snow as this a John baby although that
might not necessarily be his name
because book Aegon the baby is a
completely different character and
everyone believes that he is the true
born son of Rhaegar it was swapped out
for another baby when the mountain came
to kill him as well as Elia Martell so
you know that the TV show is completely
cut that character out there are a lot
of theories that he could be a false
lead he could be the mummer's dragon in
just a Blackfyre and not the true born
son of Rhaegar Targaryen but another big
part of the prophecy of the prince who
was promised in the prophecy of azor
Ahai is the idea of the comet it's a
headset that really big mystical [ __ ] is
going on in the background and when the
baby Aegon was born there was a comet in
the sky so at first glance there's a lot
of conflicting evidence for who the
prince who was promised is where this
vision is taking place but I think we
can trust Daenerys as visions more than
we can trust other characters trying to
remember things that they weren't
present for the really clever way that
the TV show is found around this has
been brands flashback visions where he
literally witnesses things and then you
have other characters that are actually
responsible for doing things Jon Snow
King the North Queen Daenerys coming to
King's Landing to conquer Westeros who
really don't think too much about
prophecy so a lot of the things that the
prophecies talk about people coming
together a mythical leader figure need
happen anyway in real life so that's
part of the reason why the show doesn't
dwell on prophecy too much it's just
sort of seeding things in the background
to let you know the direction the story
is going so this really cool character
that we've been following this whole
time that just came back from the dead
and became king of the north
may have also been the prince who was
promised in Daenerys his vision but
Daenerys herself might also be the one
born amidst salt and smoke who is the
coming of Ozora high everyone loves to
hype up conflict the show doesn't like
to make things too easy for characters
so there has to be some sort of conflict
before everyone comes together to fight
the white walkers in season eight or
whatever is going to be happening in the
final season there's definitely some big
things they're going to hold back but
characters are starting to slowly
converge there are several big conflicts
that have to happen before they do that
Cersei and the Lannisters aren't going
anywhere anytime soon but the big twist
of the prophecy of the prince who was
promised as well as the prophecy of azor
Ahai is that the source material that
they're all taken from is actually high
Valyrian so the prophecy is a Valyrian
prophecy which is a gender-neutral
language so the big theory now is that
it's not so much a twist that oh you
thought it was a prince but really it's
a princess because at the beginning of
season five Varys has that very specific
line when he's talking to Tyrion where
he says who said anything about him the
stronger idea though is that there is no
one mythical figure because like a lot
of other characters say put no faith and
prophecy everyone misinterprets prophecy
even Melisandre who has visions has no
idea what's going on she's just trying
to figure things out as she goes along
is the idea that both Jon Snow and
Daenerys are the fulfillment of the
prophecy because as the prophecy has
been translated it's been misinterpreted
and it's not a road map as it is sort of
a general guidebook big warning sign
look you need to come together in order
to fight this so you get a lot better
context when you actually look at what
the other cultures say about these
mythical savior figures in the long
night itself but like I said the whole
reason for all of this and finding out
about the idea of a prince who was
promised is the long night itself in
fighting White Walkers practically which
is what you'll see play out on the TV
show the other stuff like azor Ahai
talking about the mythical say
figure we'll just be in the background
to make you perk your ears up and go hey
wait a minute who are they talking about
the show very rarely addresses stuff
like that even when Jon Snow came back
from the dead all Melisandre wanted to
know was what he saw on the other side
and he said he saw nothing
it was blackness I never want to come
back from that do not bring me back if I
die again so let me know in the comments
just based on this scene here that
they're teasing how do you think the
show is going to reveal the idea of the
prince who is promised in as aura high
and what is it going to do with that is
it just going to be a throwaway moment
for the fans or is it going to be more
like Circe's prophecy where even though
you see it play out on the TV show in
the future they never directly verbally
address it after the characters read
about it the really big thing is coming
up next Sunday is American Gods is
premiering on Starz in the United States
in Amazon internationally so in the next
couple of days I'm going to do a trailer
video for that just explaining the broad
concepts of the series some of you
probably know all about it or have read
the book already it's a lot like Game of
Thrones if it were told from the
perspective of the Gods is going to be
crazy so make sure you watch it when it
airs next Sunday but leave all your
requests for Game of Thrones videos in
the comments below
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Rafael Nunez please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details click
here for all my Game of Thrones season 7
promo breakdowns and you can click here
for a brand new black panther thank you
so much for watching let's high five
I'll see you guys in the next video
Oh